Performing "Homesick"
from her album
"Natural Brown Prom Queen,"
please welcome Sudan Archives!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Song begins ]
♪♪
♪ You think I'm pretty ♪
♪ I think you're gorgeous ♪
♪ I think you're arrogant ♪
♪ You think I'm flawless ♪
♪ I think you're mad at me ♪
♪ You think I am, too ♪
♪ Don't worry, baby ♪
♪ I wanna be like you ♪
♪ Gorgeous and arrogant ♪
♪ Gorgeous and arrogance ♪
♪ Roses and arrogance ♪
♪ I love the smell of it ♪
♪ Gorgeous and arrogance ♪
♪ Roses and piles of -- ♪
♪ Roses and piles of spit ♪
♪ You want the grass green ♪
♪ I want the whole view ♪
♪ It's now or never ♪
♪ Why can't I dream, too? ♪
♪ Arrogance ♪
♪ Arrogance, arrogance,
arrogance ♪
♪ Sweet arrogance ♪
♪♪
♪ He ran along down the Five ♪
♪ Told him pick up some wine ♪
[ Glass dings ]
♪ Then he came back with
Little Caesars ♪
♪ Arugula, and some wine ♪
♪ Now that's my type of guy ♪
♪♪
♪ Walked up in the house,
sat upon the couch ♪
♪ It's evident,
turned on "One Piece" ♪
♪ And this often goes, ♪
♪ Hand-in-hand,
then "Initial D" ♪
♪ That's his favorite show
currently ♪
♪ But when you gon'
give me some D? ♪
♪♪
♪ Last week,
you was all over me ♪
♪♪
♪ I haven't been
actin' that sweet ♪
♪♪
♪ I haven't been
actin' like me ♪
♪ I know, I know, I know ♪
♪ I know things haven't
been the same ♪
♪ The rona's made us go insane ♪
♪ Your baby mama
actin' strange ♪
♪ And my twin and my friends
always in here ♪
♪ But when you gon'
give me some D? ♪
♪♪
♪ I just want the D-I-C-K ♪
♪ Problems is not
what I'm seekin' ♪
♪ I just miss my homie TK ♪
♪ I just miss my Mama
Shay Shay ♪
♪ I just want the D-I-C-K ♪
♪ Problems is not what
I'm seekin' ♪
♪ I just miss my homie TK ♪
♪ I just miss my Mama
Shay Shay ♪
♪ Heyyyy ♪
♪ Homesick ♪
♪♪
♪ Stale feelings ♪
♪ Homesick ♪
♪ [ Cheers and applause ] ♪